The second trailer for "Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness" arrived just
ahead of the 2022 Super Bowl, and holy
Sorcerer Supreme, it was totally epic.
met — it is up to Strange and his allies to find
a way to put his own world back together again.
as well as Christine Palmer. Elizabeth
Olsen will also join forces with Doctor
Strange as Wanda Maximoff, debuting the
next phase in Scarlet Witch's powers
as she aids her fellow Supreme Being and
guides him in the ways of the multiverse.
Amidst all of the madness, there are a handful
of small but oh-so-intriguing details that
tease just how complex and far-reaching Doctor
Strange's next adventure in the MCU will be.
At about the 40-second mark in
the trailer, you can see a bleak,
faded-out shot of New York City buildings
dissolving into nothingness, implying that
Dr. Strange has somehow caused a rift that will
unravel reality. This isn't the first time we've
seen Dr. Strange's bad behavior lead to this
civilization-ending type of disruption. If you
saw the fourth episode of the animated series
"What If...?" you may recognize that effect.
In that episode, "What If...Dr. Strange Lost
His Heart Instead of His Hands," Dr. Strange's
girlfriend Christine is in the car with him when
he has the accident that, in the original movie,
damaged his hands. Dr. Strange becomes a Master
of the Mystic Arts and uses the Eye of Agamotto
to manipulate time. He uses it to
try and save her — only to find,
in a series of heartbreaking vignettes, that
this just isn't possible. In desperately trying
to find a way to save her, he becomes
split into two versions — one evil,
and one good. They fight and create a
paradox that begins to tear reality apart.
The dissolving effect in "What If..." looks
darker and inkier than what's happening in "Dr.
Strange and the Multiverse of Madness," but the
dissolving of reality has a similar feel to it,
and the callback appears to result
from the same type of misdeed on Dr.
Strange's part — we'll just have
to wait to find out what that is.
One of the most explosive sequences in
the new "Multiverse of Madness" trailer
depicts the titular sorcerer being led down a
corridor in handcuffs, to a massive room where
several prominent figures — their faces currently
unrevealed — are seated. While little is confirmed
in the trailer, it has long been rumored that
the movie will introduce a multiverse-flavored
version of the Illuminati, a shady group that, in
the comics, is comprised of such major heroes as
Doctor Strange, Reed Richards, Tony Stark, Namor,
and Charles Xavier whenever they want to plan some
shady happenings. If the trailer is any indication
— and if the Illuminati rumors prove true — then
it seems that the army of Ultron robots leading
Strange are their personal guards and soldiers.
As for who will comprise the MCU Illuminati?
There have long been rumors of alternate universe
versions of characters seen in prior Marvel
projects and this would be the place where
they would most likely show up. The Illuminati
could include, for instance, an alternate universe
version of Tony Stark (though that seems
unlikely) or Reed Richards (John Krasinski,
perhaps?), as well as Mordo (played by Chiwetel
Ejiofor). Perhaps the most mind-blowing inclusion,
though, would be Charles Xavier — which makes
it all the more intriguing that during this
scene of the trailer, there is a moment where
we appear to hear the voice of Patrick Stewart,
the actor who previously brought the
X-Men leader to life in the Fox films.
Will the mysterious Illuminati appear in
the film, or are these Ultron guards just
spinning us in the wrong direction? For now,
fans are eagerly awaiting more information.
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
looks like it will bring more characters
from Marvel's vast library into the MCU. The
latest trailer features a cameo from Rintrah,
an alien creature that was inspired by the
minotaurs of Greek mythology. Originating from
the extradimensional planet R'Vaal, Rintrah is an
intelligent being who possesses supreme strength,
as well as sorcerer abilities such as magic and
shapeshifting. The original Rintrah is green,
however, so it's clear that Sam Raimi and co. have
taken some creative liberties with his appearance.
Rintrah has been an ally to Strange in the comics
in the past. At one point he even served as his
apprentice, though he eventually made the leap to
becoming a full-fledged sorcerer in his own right.
The minotaur is also known for his
association with Enitharmon the Weaver,
a powerful and reclusive magician who resides in
an alternate dimension. If Rintrah is in the hotly
anticipated sequel, then it's very possible that
his old mentor will make an appearance as well.
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness" arrives in theaters on May 6th.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU movies and shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.